if we accepted everybody we would be
larger than Iceland the Free Republic of
liberland is the world's newest
sovereign state lying on seven square
kilometers for unclaimed land nestled
between Croatia and Serbia
founded in April 2015 by Liberty centric
politician vigil Edgar liberal lands
motto is to live and let live and their
goal is to find the minimum amount of
taxes and regulation necessary to exist
there welcoming to anyone with a respect
for private ownership who is tolerant of
other people in their beliefs regardless
of race ethnicity orientation or
religion
oh it tried for five years to show
people that we might not have enough
Liberty in Czech Republic's same around
the world we've got taxes for regular
working people as high as 60%
we've got 360,000 people from all around
the world somehow registered on the
website if we accepted everybody we
would be larger than Iceland we've got
now people who were building hong kong
building shanghai who were building
dubai we've got 600 architects on our
list of citizens present-day America
would not be mistaken for a limited
government utopia but liberal and draft
constitution is modeled on the United
States for 200 years you had a pretty
decent level of freedom here and I think
we took the best out of that and we
transferred it to our Constitution but
we were much stricter on government you
know there is a direct ban on government
to do for example any laws on public
education and it wasn't public health
care system and it also marriage so no
more talk about these gay marriage or
any other marriage because government
will have nothing to say in these areas
unsurprisingly
liberal land will not be part of the
euro zone but they have proposed an
interesting alternative we are not going
to create a currency we are going to
create this merit system where we will
be able to evaluate how much energy
people brought to the project and
according to that they will be able to
get the citizenship despite liberal
lands quest to keep government to a
minimum
it does not intend to be a lawless state
yeah we have to find that minimum amount
of regulation that will make us
acceptable for the international
community that means we do have to have
these set of laws on anti money
laundering
you do have to have this set laws laws
on illegal drug trafficking but we are
trying to find the minimum always the
minimum amount of regulation necessary
to get one started
liberal and success is in no way assured
Croatia has been arresting eager liberal
and settlers and creating an ethnically
heterogenous nation state without
decades of immigration is a tall order
still julika believes in the mission for
me it's most important to establish
really strong international global
community of people like-minded people
who are serious about spreading Liberty
all around the world we will have a
chance to establish a country there if
it's mainly about love and freedom